he's wrong it's it's [ __ ] up female
promiscuity is disgusting to the point
where females were executed for it blah
blah blah
don't call me a misogynistic drop dead
tape
at the moment our andrew takes craziest
takes is that i think 150 000 views
first video i'm top g i know the
algorithms like the back of my hand i'm
the man big deal put yourself together
oh my god so i don't even need to give
you an introduction i say we just get
right into it but before that i'm giving
away a hundred dollars every video to
someone who
likes subscribes and then they like
subscribe to join the discord join the
discord that's where change your life
baby come on what's your discord what's
that is quarterback i only have kevin um
this is tristan or andrew this is andrew
tristan's a terrible name but that's too
bad i hear this all the time oh but he's
my friend we like hanging out hanging
out why hello to do what
play video games make jokes ha ha he's
so funny
jerk each other off
the [ __ ] you doing
if your friends aren't talking about
money why are you talking to them
facts
yeah yeah listen you become the average
of the five people you spend the most
time with the most time you should spend
with people who you want to be like
absolutely but that's inner circle out
next second circle you know what hang
out with friends that have a little bit
of hard luck or just can't get their
[ __ ] together maybe you can help them a
little once in a while you know you can
enjoy their company and maybe inspire
them to do something with themselves i
definitely do agree that for the most
part you should be surrounding yourself
with people that you're all trying to
better yourselves with i'm sorry you're
like yeah if you're hanging out lose a
friend and they make you laugh that's
therapy laughing's good he's too strict
he's got a light there's a reason
there's a reason he's they're the
[ __ ] he's got a hundred million i'd
rather have 50 million and be a little
more relaxed not that i have 50 million
but you know
give him the choice though
you win your 50 mil
i will never ever wear headphones in
public when you put your headphones in
and you're walking down the street
listening to your music
you are a [ __ ]
target i do this all the time all the
time take those headphones out so you
can hear what's going on around you
don't i yes no you do yeah yeah and i
stopped doing it actually oh yeah no
because he said it not because i said it
i know i stopped doing it before this
[ __ ] guy blew up i was walking to the
gym one day and i'm walking and there's
a one of those what's the thing the
gutter i don't know if my ear my thing
falls out of my ear does 20 bounces on
the rim and falls down the dream it's
good and since then i've just borne one
ear bud good for you but that also
opened me up to the fact that damn i
really am much more aware of my
surroundings good cause we live in the
city you know i'm not gonna you would be
in a little like you gotta have street
smarts there's people that are literally
walking around like a country bumpkin
like waiting to get mugged yeah no
there's people that will literally walk
around with noise-cancelling headphones
on in the city at night and that is just
completely idiotic we should go mug them
we should go mug them teach them a
lesson
give me your crypto [ __ ] open it
up maybe they get 2500 watches most
important sensory perceptions i'll tell
you something man i've been jumped four
times every time i was jumped i didn't
see it coming i heard it coming yeah
cause they're not gonna run at you
they're gonna hit you from behind behind
or the side no that's that's a great
point street smarts street smarts this
is the guy that's the type of guy that's
the type of guy and he's like
i i want you to know that i've watched
all your videos and you say some
misogynistic views
pipes it out and he expects me to be
like
no
don't call me a misogyny
what am i gonna do my private jet won't
fly my super cars won't start all my
beautiful women will no longer sleep
with me my diamonds won't shine please
don't type that in no please i'm not a
massage i don't
give
a [ __ ] i don't care if they ban me i
don't care if they cancel me i don't
give a [ __ ] i love that mentality so
much where you just don't give a [ __ ] if
you get cancelled or not because you
know what my income doesn't rely on some
[ __ ] system above me where if i say
something that doesn't agree to their
agenda i get fired i can literally say
whatever i want yes yes yes you're
absolutely right and i agree with you i
need you to drop like 50
fewer f-bombs i also agree though as
long as you're not deliberately hurting
anybody that you should yes you should
not care but you should also remember to
not hurt anybody
you know i'm not saying stuff to go
after people and hurt
sensitive people that get offended by bs
yeah right we don't care about them like
they're not they're irrational like
that's asian drivers joe it's not all
women that are worse drivers than men
it's asian women most actually there was
more love for that comment than hate
everyone just thought it was funny and
they think it's funny that we don't give
a [ __ ] and that we don't give a [ __ ] i
just want to point out as you know the
adult in the room that it's important to
be kind that's our jam thank you mommy
but i all you're welcome baby um but i
also am so glad that you don't care
because i think it's really unhealthy to
have every word that comes out of your
mouth
be
so measured because you're afraid of
making somebody upset some irrational
lunatic upset no thanks cancel me go
ahead try i hope you canceled me
vegan i didn't know she was a vegan
unfortunately i found out she said i'll
never cook meat for you i said look well
i'll be honest with you right now we're
gonna end up splitting up we're living
in my house and i'm paying the bills if
i want steak you're cooking it that was
a good two-hour argument until she
eventually cooked the steak of course
she did what's she gonna do lose me cook
the steak she sat there she pretended
she was upset two weeks later she's
eating me i converted
one person at a time i'm gonna fix the
world you're silly
what a silly goose i've decided to come
out as a woman because how i look
obviously has no bearing on the fact of
what gender i am when i was thinking of
transitioning i thought i had to look
like a girl but it turns out i don't i
can keep my shaved head in my beard
because if you assume i'm a man for
those reasons you're a bigot also i
thought i'd have to have sex with men
but i realized i could be a lesbian i'd
have to change basically anything about
my life i can just be exactly the same
as i am now but i am now officially a
woman because if you do not agree with
that you are a bigoted individual but
it's okay i just want people to
recognize me for who i really feel like
i am
inside i'm proud of him he's a great
brave
courageous he's so brave maybe he'll be
warming in the year next year
imagine
what they've done that they've made men
women of the year no i can't
join you you should join the women's ufc
and just kick the [ __ ] out of everybody
isn't there a dude in the women's boxing
arena i don't think so that would be
that's some [ __ ] you go to the streets
and protest for because that's messed up
no wait we gotta we gotta google it i
mean i can't believe they let leah
thomas win that award let alone
i'm not let's next video press to sit
there go up the proof
cause you're broke just fat cause you're
losing
nobody told you at any point you're
supposed to be happy all of the time
you're not supposed to be happy
happiness is on top of a mountain and
you [ __ ] ain't hurt
so i'm thinking of all the things that
make me happy
in fact i'm my beautiful physique
my house these [ __ ] whatever i do
whatever i enjoy at the moment
uh all had to be earned it's true
that's a man you got to earn all that
[ __ ] you're not born with any of it
a little modesty could go a long way i
know i know it's the cold hard truth mom
it's the cold hard truth that needs to
wake people the [ __ ] up and start
grinding enough with this soft [ __ ]
it's not tough to be kind don't don't
make me hurt you
need super cars outside a club right
listen to lambos outside and dudes are
trying to break in even though i know
the locks the alarm the immobilizer is
solid am i gonna allow them to try no so
if i have a chick even though i know she
won't let them smash even though i know
she knows what they're about and even
though i know she's loyal to me out of
respect for me it's not jealousy it's
territorialism if you want me to truly
love you you are my girl and no one's
going to be allowed to even try even
though i know you won't let them do you
understand what i'm saying to you
because how am i supposed to have a
chick i truly love and care about when
every dude in the world can just hit on
her even if she says no just hit an
honor non-stop if you want to go to the
club you can go with me i'm going to go
to maldives baby i'll take it
i wonder if it's different for him
because he literally dates like some of
the most beautiful women i've ever seen
on the internet i don't know but i i
think that's i don't know because
they're i think like a little much some
guys are like that with with you know
beastly broads too so it's fine it's an
attitude it's not just about the beauty
it's like i'm not a fan of if i'm dating
a girl or something and her going out
and doing all that [ __ ] she's not going
to a [ __ ] frat party i'll tell you
that i'm done with those girls [ __ ]
girls who love frat guys oh my god i
love cigarette boys like why are you so
obsessed with this dude he literally had
to pay thousands of dollars and drink a
cup of [ __ ] to make some friends if she
idolizes frat guys drop her
she likes frat guys she's cut the [ __ ]
off watch the f-bombs your mother's here
your mother's here i'm done i'm done but
i don't know she goes to a club or
something like i feel like girls just
like going to club i don't know like
damn it really does make me think
because like why are you going to the
club it depends on the girl when i was
out with my friends and i was in a
relationship if guys were hitting on me
i wasn't like
oh yeah and like going into it i'd be
like i'm boyfriend bye and i'd walk away
like i just scooted away so fast i
didn't sit and flirt but a lot of women
high value woman a lot of women do a lot
of women just thrive on any attention
even if they're not gonna go down that
road they just love the the moment of
attention and so if you got a girl like
that you know if you got a girl like
that yeah so he he shouldn't be like you
can't go without me like drop dead tape
don't mess with me about the question
because i don't believe it
if you're asleep in your bed in the
middle of the night you hear a noise and
you believe in ghosts
now you're afraid but if you don't
believe in ghosts that's the wind and
you go back to sleep you give the ghosts
power by believing in them your house is
only haunted if you believe in ghosts
belief is a powerful thing how to stand
in front of you
that house is haunted but i could punch
you i'm not a fan
and i could fracture it and send a
splinter into your heart would you allow
me to try
you wouldn't because you know i believe
i can
i believe i could hurt any man on the
planet and that's why people are afraid
and you believe depression is a
crippling disease and that's why you're
afraid of it
it's so mean and shitty depression is a
real disease just because he doesn't
believe in it doesn't mean it doesn't
exist like someone's like i don't
believe in god i'm like that doesn't
mean it doesn't exist he doesn't believe
in depression it's there's chemical
depression there's pts just like how
there's crazy people with like things
like schizophrenia and [ __ ] like that
where it's like legit mental disorders
you're just saying that there's legit
chemical imbalances in your brain that
will that can make you depressed
absolutely the way i try to look at it
is like if i like i can't get depressed
like just go to the gym stick to your
goals and like i can't get to i don't i
don't know that's the way i look at it
and it's it's very healthy for me and it
works i think i don't have anything i
think it's a blessing but i don't have
like clinical depression with like a
chemical imbalance in my brain so i i
guess i really can't fully know but
right it's hard that's the way that's
the way i look at it like i really i do
really like that take there's some
people who will take a circumstantial
depression like this happens this
happened you know i think that's most of
depression though i think that's most of
depression it's not mostly a chemical
imbalance in your brain i think it's
people being told that depression is
real and that it can affect them and
that is disease that they can't control
in that they should just be sad about it
rather than telling people that they
should do things like go to the gym and
make money i think that trying like it's
just a healthier mindset of not
acknowledging it and trying to better
yourself i don't think so i don't think
most of the time it's really a chemical
imbalance in people's brains
i i can't i can't talk about most of
what but i can tell you for sure that
circumstantial depression sometimes
people over younger people especially
overdo it they go all in and they jump
in the deep end and they're like oh what
was me and i can never and then it's the
end of the world but i can also tell you
that there is there are people who go to
the gym they eat right they're healthy
they take their antidepressants they do
all the things maybe it's because they
take those [ __ ] pills even if they
don't take the things they do all the
things that you're talking about and
they still are just there's something
wrong in their mind that's chemical and
it's not so so it's really it's not for
us first of all he's not a psychiatrist
he's not a doctor i also i see his point
on the social conversation around
depression where it's made to be such a
thing where everyone's like oh me too
like it's one of those you know oh yeah
i'm depressed i'm depressed but he's
he's wrong he's wrong it's it's [ __ ]
up to just minimize an actual disease
it's being like you're cancer you don't
have cancer [ __ ] get that out of your
head you don't have cancer it's not cool
if you're the kind of person who feels
like they need therapy you're useless
because in the harshest realities of
this whole world there are people in
syria whose entire families have been
blown to [ __ ] who are still getting up
every day making [ __ ] bread and
selling on the streets so they have
enough money to buy a new pair of
sandals sometime next year
you're a useless [ __ ] it's an
interesting way of putting it but i
think his like overall point and if you
look deeper into it it's saying that you
should just get over it and move on with
your life yeah and keep improving rather
than letting trauma get to you in a
negative way let it go
man and it it's an extreme view and i
don't think it covers everybody i i
think though it probably does cover 90
of issues and
people want to just sit and talk about
their problems and i've done it like in
my youth i did that and you know what it
never really got me anywhere the only
thing that ever got me anywhere was just
saying
all right i'm over it and moving on like
just learn a lesson and carry on and go
build something he's he's right you got
to just carry on it's enough with the
complaining
it's paying someone 100 bucks an hour to
hear you complain get a coach a life
coach a life coach is a lot better
someone who just helps you you don't
dwell on your problems you're not
dwelling in the past he's just taking
you like meeting you where you are and
taking you forward i agree not this
happened to you oh i'm sorry how did it
make you feel oh i bet you felt really
bad think about how you felt [ __ ] that
yeah [ __ ] that there's not a female on
the planet who's invisible today you can
be a four you'll still go to the club
and get attention 99 of the men go to
the club and nobody even can talk to
them they try and talk to a girl they
get blanked and ignored and told the
[ __ ] off most men are absolutely not
really invisible this is the truth about
masculinity it's very easy for women to
sit here and complain about the top two
percent of men most men don't even
exist they send 10 000 dm's and never
even get read let alone replied to so if
you just sit here and say i'll get a g a
big g a boss a millionaire and let him
have a day off very nice of you i'm sure
you would but if a guy who wanted to
have days off all the time he never
would have gotten important enough in
the first place to attract a woman like
you and that is the reality
sounds bad but if it's like a girl's
objective to go to like a club and like
kiss three people
it's it's literally like it's the
easiest thing in the world for her to do
that if it's a guy's job to go and do
that it's it's totally different it's
way harder plus if you're an ugly guy
it's almost seen as like rapey and
sexually assaultish if you even try to
talk to girls because if you're ugly and
you try to talk to even better-looking
girls even with good-looking guys they
do that everything is no it's worse with
bad looking guys if you're a bad looking
guy you're [ __ ] like you're actually
it's such it's way more right it's way
more of a crap situation
but that's how it is those guys are
going to do very well in 20 years you
know whenever the ladies have run
through all their options nice guys do
finish last but they finish
throughout the majority of human history
female promiscuity has been absolutely
frowned upon only in the western world
we're going to pretend it's an okay
thing every single culture says the
daughter of human time and every single
place on the planet has said that female
promiscuity is disgusting to the point
where females were executed for it yeah
and most of the world today as they
should be
get the rocks yeah abdul
get the rocks
of the world today it's still frowned
upon it's unacceptable whereas every
single king insulted and shake since the
dawn of human time had multiple women
men are allowed multiple women women are
not allowed multiple men because if a
woman has multiple men you cannot ensure
paternity and the modern science of the
devil just because we can work out how
the dad is doesn't mean the actions yeah
just because that's the way it's been
done throughout history doesn't make it
right we also used to have slavery and
torture in the middle ages like things
that are completely
outdated so you know that his argument
is super flimsy on that one well that
reasoning for it is flimsy saying people
have done it forever like that's not a
good reason yeah but i definitely have
heard better reasons for it that have
like opened my mind to it more and like
kind of like more understanding towards
it to the idea of it how hard it's gonna
be for me to have like a daughter-in-law
to deal with and if you come home with
three four five daughter-in-laws and i
get to deal with all these young girls i
don't believe in i don't believe in
marriage in the first place girlfriends
whatever my [ __ ]
not happening i start breaking kneecaps
i do think that the promiscuity among
young girls nowadays to the point where
not like you know i'm not judging
but i think
we do whatever you want to do it's fine
have a great time but i think being you
know proud of it and calling that
progress for women
and saying you know i can i can after
whoever i want and i can then i can and
i'll have an abortion every time i get
pregnant and i'll do all these things
like you're just haram it's just
it's just cheap and it doesn't promote
it doesn't help women move forward and
that's what they're doing they're like i
can be a total [ __ ] and don't call me a
[ __ ] it's an it's yeah no no it's gross
it lowers the value of that woman as bad
as that sounds to say it's true when a
guy's looking at a woman he doesn't want
someone that's that she's been with a
lot of people because men want loyalty
and they want like a sense of scarcity
and purity in a woman i think it's not
so bad
it's not it's like it's such a gross
thought i can't stand that phrase right
and through that's just rude if she's
read through like
if she got mileage
can't do it she fought at streets no but
men also like conquest they like to be
predators they want to pray as he says
men also don't want to pray that's you
know he says men also like stat want
status which is very true and if you're
with a girl who's been with the whole
town your status isn't that high bro
everyone's been with her and that's your
girl now
yeah [ __ ] that no you didn't have to
catch her she was just sitting there
waiting like a scared bunny no that's
not there's no hunting involved there's
a reason why people like what's hard to
get that's that's a natural thing in
almost every human like there could be a
ten a nine who's really easy and i'd be
like ugh like it's not it's not as you
know attractive and compared to like a
six or a seven who makes it a lot harder
i feel like i would go after that more
yeah it's just natural
um because it's harder it gives you
something to work for or you win
something to earn to win you know if
you're with the town ho it's not as it's
not as valuable i don't know why this is
such a debate and you're called sexism
well i'm sure it's fun in the moment and
there's a party and then it's great but
there is not yeah girls act like that
and they think that that's going to be
what gets them
you know true love in a ring and
and there's multiple other factors that
goes into it i mean there's statistics
that show the higher women's body count
is the higher the divorce rate there's
literally statistics on that but
who knows
that doesn't mean she's happily married
okay do you eat salon i want to open a
beauty salon why do you want to open a
beauty salon oh because you know i
really like makeup and i'm really good
at makeup and i watch these things on
youtube about makeup and my friend
claire is really good at makeup and i
know all these girls who need their
makeup done and it's really hard to get
your makeup done properly and i will be
the place you can get your makeup done
properly it's going to become called
beauty elysium and everyone's going to
come and they'll get their makeup done
and it's going to be a big successful
business so i just need you to rent me a
building and put gucci sofas in and get
me a nice sexy sign and cover the whole
place in flowers and spend all your
money so that i can at 11 45 crawl out
of bed with a [ __ ] cappuccino and
walk in there with my hair [ __ ]
curled like a ceo and a little girl suit
and look around all my customers and all
the money i'm making and have them do my
makeup and then i'll go off for lunch at
two o'clock and we'll be millionaires
it's so funny because like i know the
exact kind of girls he's talking about
yeah you know what i mean just like
straight bimbos that's hilarious but men
do this too though yeah yeah they just
they're going to open a business without
any plan any actual business sense it's
all i love his point
to start up when you start a business
you need to look at how you can start it
and start making money without even
spending money that's where i teach i
teach how to get as much organic
marketing done on your business as pos
like as possible without any ad spend
yeah and that's what i started you
started with literally that's what i did
with my company we generated over five
million dollars with literally zero
dollars in marketing budget just you
know you don't invest any money i didn't
ask for investments from from anybody i
didn't ask for handouts from parents
none of that [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] that they have convinced people to
spend 50 60 700 000 pounds to go to
university get in debt to learn business
from a dude who's never had a business
with no money
i said this on a video
it's true
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
doing
have you lost your mind
it's [ __ ] that everyone knows it's
[ __ ] and they've done it because
they've managed to get the educational
system to operate inside of a vacuum
they've managed to link the loan with
the educational system so it's vacuum
it's a vacuum and it can't be compared
fairly to any other service when they
convince people to go to these schools
they get you in debt early that's what
they want now you have to get a job you
have to get nine to five you just keep
paying it off because you understand
that the whole system is rigged and
you've been [ __ ] from the beginning
there's so much around that
the mentality that having a you know
getting a job is the only way to make a
living make a life you can't get a job
without a college you need a college
degree yeah who the why the [ __ ] do i
need a college degree i'm 18 years old
and i can guarantee you i'm more
qualified for any marketing or like most
business jobs than any other dude with
like a degree just because i've run a
business over the last i would never
i've learned way more i would never make
a degree whenever i go into business i
take [ __ ] over i have proved that myself
without a degree at 18. why do i need a
degree it is [ __ ] i learned from
youtube from the start mostly i bought
some online courses learned from them
some of them were [ __ ] some of them
were good you learned
maybe what that was a 75 mistake oh no
i'm fine i didn't get myself into 80 000
debt and 12 years of working just to pay
it off unless you're going into law or
medicine which are essentially trades
just you know white collar trades
everything else i agree with you there's
not much you you can't learn on your own
i have a lot of respect for people who
go right into trades i mean i personally
wouldn't want to do that i would because
i'm just more entrepreneurial but at
least they recognize you could you could
have that too you go into the plumbing
trade and you become a mover
and then you and then you start your own
you buy your first truck you start your
own company look at what our my my
parents did yeah with the limousine
business they had a super successful
limousine business in new york city and
my father never even graduated from high
school yeah no because he had a brain
and he understood quality and he knew
how to run things and grandma was like
what i was just saying is i'm i'm more
entrepreneurial and i understand the
true value in the internet and digital
marketing so i wouldn't need to go into
an in-person business like that
all of my business has been done online
from home on my computer that's how i've
made all my money right so when this
whole
and if i wanted to you have to go to
college things started it was before the
you know that mentality started it was
before the internet it's such an old
mentality yeah it's so old
i just think that the learning there
anybody that says i can't do this or i
can't do that because i can't afford no
school no everything is right here
everything that you know everyone is
the most the most what angers me is when
people say i don't know where to start
[ __ ]
google it bro yeah my friend was talking
to me the other day he's like yeah i
want to start a podcast i just don't
know where to start sorry i'm sorry he's
watching this but it's like bro [ __ ]
look it up yeah what are you what are
you what are you sitting around waiting
for what cam everyone asked me what
camera to use bro buy a [ __ ] camera
there it's a camera like dude the first
people overthink everything and you're
killing yourself by overthinking this
non-stop you put yourself into analysis
paralysis where you don't get anything
done you have to make moves i've started
dozens of businesses over the last year
and a few of them have made seven
figures
yeah there's a there there's that is a
huge part of it analysis paralysis
another thing is that instead of
whenever you have a question you should
always just try to find the answer
yourself first before you ask anybody if
you can look it up if you can open a
book find it yourself because you're
more likely to remember and care about
the answer but then you've got like the
the girl who was talking about talking
to hate claire you know imaginary claire
about the the beauty salon she'll
probably you know somebody like that
will come back and go well i asked for
an investor and they got shut down
instead of just you know going out and
telling everybody she knows that she
does makeup i'll do makeup for weddings
and then go build a reputation and you
start growing and you start doing it you
save up and you open that salon yourself
you can do whatever the hell you want
you know provided it's not something you
need a license for like brain surgery
but there's no excuse i there's no
excuse and i know when i'm not
accomplishing something it's my own damn
fault
that's what i'm saying same people blame
the current president all this [ __ ]
nah man excuses are [ __ ]
wake up all right well if you want to
learn to get [ __ ] done
i have my discord for all of us
like-minded individuals who are trying
to grind and make stacks so
join that um yeah
yeah join it can i get i don't even know
how to what's a discord like i kind
i don't know i got to get in there but
yeah guys join my discord i do a lot of
announcements and stuff in there calls
let's join it up bye
there's a everybody [ __ ] crack in the
facade i'd rather writing on the wall
won't last long